Nandi staples of Sports Illustrated kind
enough to join us here on the show how
are you Andy
I'm good listen to that impassioned
pleas for the big ten and I say this as
a graduate of the school in the mighty
SEC okay that's the best conference in
America is the ACC the ACC yeah now that
they're the most stacked at the top and
they've got some some good middle the
Big Ten the middle getting better but
it's not quite as good in the middle and
obviously the top of the Big Ten is very
very good so but yeah if you had to pick
which two leagues might produce two
playoff participants the ACC and the Big
Ten would be the do you pick well ACC
would be obviously Clemson and you still
choose Florida State despite the fact
that Francois has done for the year I
don't know that he goes Florida State
although I will say that defense will
keep them in almost everything you know
anybody who tells you they know what is
going to happen with James Blackmun as
their starting quarterback is lying to
you the guy got to campus two months ago
nobody knows you know that the players
all praised him pretty lavishly Jimbo
Fisher does he's ready but you know I
got to figure out is that something that
you have to say to talk yourself into it
at this point or is he really that ready
because this is a year where a bunch of
true freshman quarterback it seems like
have to be ready
you know Kasim Hill at Maryland comes in
and and saves them against Texas
Jake Fromm's gonna start for Georgia
against Notre Dame it's it's a crazier
like that but so I would say Clemson
maybe Florida State but also maybe
Louisville also maybe Miami also maybe
Virginia Tech the ACC's got some very
good games well I mean I didn't even
mention Maryland beaten Texas by the way
when I was talking about the Big Ten and
so so who else in the ACC I mean top to
bottom do you would you say can pound
the table for the conference compared to
the Big Ten and the SEC Andy well the
SEC is not in that conversation yet
Auburn and LSU need to do some stuff or
Georgia or Florida or some well Florida
we saw last week maybe not but all burn
LSU Georgia need to do some stuff to get
the SEC even in that conversation
because at this point it
Alabama and everybody else and has been
for a little while but the ACC you know
NC State did Lucy South Carolina but
they are still loaded it depends on the
defensive line it was a game they
statistically dominated but South
Carolina has a quarterback and having a
quarterback will change things for you
but Miami's one that I pay attention to
we will see what happens when they go
into Tallahassee next week if they can
finally break that losing streak against
Florida State I think that means Miami's
ready to ready to compete
Andy staples of Sports Illustrated here
in the DirecTV for K college football
report how much smoke is there in Texas
a.m. with Kevin Sumlin after that 44 210
blown lead and a Regent taking to
Facebook to vent like he is an old man
on the porch telling the kids get off
the lawn Andy very same thing to have
happen it's just it's one of those I had
somebody in the business call me who
works at a different school and say
should I have a conversation with my
Regents about not posting things as
those we haven't no you don't need to
because your Regents will know better
but at Texas A&M that's the sort of
thing that happens you know the ad went
on Paul Finebaum show in May on the SEC
network and said eight and five isn't
going to cut it they have to win and win
now they have to be better I think
if you wanted to put a magic number on
the season for we'll Kevin someone keep
his job I think it would be five and
three in Sec play because the attitude
of Texas A&M is we didn't pay all this
money to expand the stadium we didn't
pay all this money for these beautiful
facilities to be average in the SEC to
be four and four every single year so I
think if he could be over 500 in Sec
play
that would probably do the trick the
problem is I'm not sure I see the wins
on the schedule because I don't know
that UCLA has come back with a sign that
UCLA is some juggernaut the way they
pushed UCLA around in the first half
suggested UCLA is okay but mm I don't
know so that doesn't suggest to me that
Texas A&M can beat Alabama or LSU or all
I mean and the thing is if you lose to
all three of those you can't lose
another SEC game and it's probably he's
gone if you do mm-hmm what do you think
of Ohio State the Ohio State taking on
Oklahoma this weekend what do you think
of that why I am definitely going to
pick the Buckeyes in that game I just
think what they have on their defensive
line is just ferocious I mean when I can
name when I can name all four of your
defensive ends even you know the two
guys who rotate it as well that that
means you are deep and then I think that
Kevin Wilson is the you know toward the
end of that Indiana game kind of figured
out his play calling mojo because I mean
this is the first time he's calling
plays for JT Barrett and it looked like
he had to kind of feel his way around a
little bit and then figure it out what
worked and and this is I've been
screaming about this since a couple
years ago it felt like the the two guys
that were running the office at Ohio
State between Tom Herman and now just
forgot that JT Barrett is really good at
throwing the ball to a guy about eight
yards down the field who has his face
around there and letting that guy run
all day did you hear what I had to say
about that the other day Andy I'm not
suggesting that you listen or watch the
show every I said the same exact thing
I'm glad I'm not crazy I'm glad
everybody else I mean it's it's nuts
he's not good at throwing the ball down
the field
that's not his strength but he's a very
good decision maker when you give him
some options and you know that the drag
to Paris Campbell that he caught it you
know eight yards for the line of
scrimmage and then ran all day that
should be their signature play because
JT Barrett is devastating in the read
option run game and that the freshman
they got JK Thomas holy cow so you got
that you're gonna make the defense sweat
with that and then if you add in the
fact that he can pull that ball and hit
you know one of three different targets
six to 15 yards down the field
mm-hm I don't know how you stopped him
Andy staples of Sports Illustrated
couple more minutes with him on the
DirecTV 4k college football report give
me an upset for we
- one that we're not talking about
that's not on that radar screen right
now what do you think oh it's tough to
find enough that I was looking through
the the matchups because the the games
where somebody really highly ranked is
playing somebody they're playing
somebody good or they're playing
somebody that has no chance
well what about Pittsburgh against Penn
State what about that I don't I don't
think that through Pittsburgh's in a
beat Penn State okay I think I hate Penn
State's fans are laughing at Pitt
because Pitt went to overtime with
Youngstown State which Pitt broke my
rule of never ever ever schedule a good
FCS team because there's nothing in it
for you but I don't think the Penn State
players will underestimate Pitt because
this is a team to beat them last year
well if Western Western Michigan's at
Michigan State after Western gave us see
quite the scare and then you've got USC
against Stanford
I mean Stanford just because I don't
think it's an upset so somebody told me
the line of that USC Stanford game last
night mm-hmm holy cow
it's like USC by six or something
Stanford has had their number the last
three years very bad matchup for USC
I just can't imagine thinking you know
maybe USC wins that game but thinking
that they can beat Stanford by a
touchdown and making that the line that
seems crazy given recent history so you
see can't I mean Stanford is an upset
that that's not taken I'm taking
Stanford in that game the reason I
didn't say that you know right off the
bat is it it wouldn't you like an upset
right well I mean I mean Stanford has
the ability to get better and better and
better and even put their put its name
in the in the national championship ring
by the end of the year you never know
and the in the end the pac-12 all right
so when it all comes down to it you
think Ohio State handles business and
Penn State handles business so you're
saying basically what we're looking at
the top 10 as it currently stands right
now Stanford might beat USC and take
that apart but otherwise we're kind of
dorming between right now on the end of
the weekend correct okay really curious
about Auburn Clemson because Auburn's
offense is better but your instead of
them running it now we haven't seen it
is full strength yet - Cameron Pettway
didn't play
last week and you know they didn't
really need much helping us Georgia
Southern the thing I've been curious
about what a burden is will their
defense be as good as it was last year
because that defense kept them in a lot
of games last year and while the offense
was was just abominable in some of those
games they had a nice run in the middle
there but the office should be very good
this year if the defense is as good as
it was last year it doesn't even need to
be better just as good you're talking
about a team that can beat anybody so
I'm curious to see how Clemson with
Kelly Bryant you know facing his first
big time opponent how do they handle
that yeah now I'm of the mind that
Clemson recruits and reloads about the
same way Alabama and Ohio State do I
think those three programs are kind of
in in a class by themselves right now so
I am NOT one of those people who thinks
what Clemson did the past few years was
only because of deshaun Watson okay III
realized they've got some dudes that
nobody else has like nobody else has
Christian Wilkins nobody else has it
Dexter Lawrence so my guess is Clemson
wins that game but if Albarn hangs in
makes it close I would watch Auburn very
closely the rest of the way all right
Andy before I let you go I got about a
minute left here our poll question today
is who's the most cursed franchise in
sports what do you think is the most
cursed college football team if you won
my dad would be would would disown me if
I didn't say his alma mater the South
Carolina Gamecocks home of the chicken
curse no question I was at I was at a
pig picking in 1984 when they went up to
Navy undefeated and came back with their
their feathers between their legs okay
it's the ticket Turkey
all right Andy thanks very much you
appreciate the two cents
that's Andy staples from Sports
Illustrated at Andy underscore Staples
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to